all right let's do something different
let's see if we can conference in a few
viewers with each other so let's see let
me bring in oh this should be
interesting
let me bring on valve from Agawam first
Val are you with us tonight
hi David are you doing hey Val what's
going on
I'm doing well good so stand by with me
I'm gonna add into the feed here we've
not done this before just because it's a
very special night let's add in Brody
from now okay great Brody can you hear
me David I can't hear you Brody and Val
two past callers to the David Pakman
show please
Val I want you to take the question from
Brody and let's see what he had to say
today Brody go ahead my question
actually comes down to how are we going
to phrase and give our message about
that the overall cost to benefit ratio
with regards to health care mm-hmm I
think Bernie's stumbled out a little bit
he kind of said hey we are gonna raise
taxes but he didn't make it clear enough
that look this is going to cost you less
in the long run and be better for you
right so now I want to know how do we
how do we get our messaging on point
because yeah those Republicans got
they're gonna very good question Val can
you address this issue how can we better
explain how you are how to care for all
Rodi Rodi is it
yes it's Brody yes Brody these are my
thoughts
I thought Bernie was a little bit too
polite tonight I've seen many of his
rallies and he does go into a lot of
depth about how to handle the cost of
Medicare and he talks about the other
countries of the world that have systems
where it's single-payer and where their
health care is better and it isn't
costing them as much and I was a little
surprised he didn't go into more detail
tonight I think that would be the best
thing to do all the times that you've
heard him how easily is he able to
distill that though the times that I've
heard him like I said have been at
rallies I wish he sort of maybe would
have pretended in his mind that he was
at a rally and out of the debate and
maybe he would have been
not as timid about it um interesting I
know David have you ever have you seen
any of it I've seen Bernie be much
clearer about this whole thing of listen
there will be attacks but the tax will
be way smaller than all of the things
you're already paying for including
premiums and your interior part I just
think he was less clear about let's do
this
let's bring in Sebastian to see if he
can shed insight into Brody's questions
about Sebastian have you been listening
to this and what do you think about what
they're saying is awesome yeah I don't
really have much add on this I think I
agree with proposal you said you do okay
we should take an angle of like there's
a hidden tax like because there is a
hidden tax of not how do you know what
I'm sorry I must it must have skipped
when I got connected and I didn't hear
that part
oh dear okay that's interesting you know
I think the only solution to this is
that we pull Vivek in Vivek what do you
think about Sebastian's opinion about
how they'll handled the question from
breda all day I didn't expect to be here
caught him later
so as far as a Bernese appeal is
concerned that's what we're talking
about right like how he can yeah
how can he better as a cleaner that or
will be a tax for Medicare for all but
it's a net savings overall yeah I think
he should lead off by saying like it's
in that savings I think the way that he
went about addressing some of the
questions like for example the one where
they asked him like what is the one
policy you'd put into place like right
now your president it sounded like he
was kind of trying to dodge the
questions and I don't think that's the
best strategy he should start off just
by saying I think the way that like Kyle
kolinsky would say she would just say
like it saves money it saves money for
the American people and then like go
over briefly on how it does that
yeah I would just open I would say
listen this is a net savings we're
taking away a bunch of costs we're
adding a small payroll tax and overall
we're going to be saving a lot of money
because this is going to be a system
that overall is going to reduce the cost
for caring for each person over the
course of a year or so
what about ik waiting it like this and
starting out saying look with the
current system you pay more and get less
and with medicare-for-all or a universal
system it's the opposite like should we
approach it from that angle that's
interesting but I think it's just like
we want to make it as simple as possible
and that's not the simplest possible way
to talk about it
Sebastian are you pleased with the
direction of this conversation okay go
ahead I'm in it so let me see I'm in at
Brody great to hear from you we're gonna
let Brody go Val always great to hear
from you and appreciate the phone call
from Vic you're still on okay when the
Joseph le kinky linguist he must still
be Christiana seven to nothing Ellen
unless you can be sort of masculine
three Maria chicanery on television can
tell Jack a second oriental when he
wears Qatari early sentimentality
current art a solitary on Paco
egalitarian okay physic do you want to
handle this one
Oh should I give like a better response
and responded like broken Spanish as I
took it on like eighth grade yeah throw
them across
yeah like better yesterday to do
bilingual
dubbing of the David Pakman show we're
thinking there's a very interesting
project going on in a you know at a
university I don't even know if it's
public where a machine learning system
can take the captions from the David
Pakman show in English and spit out an
audio track in a bunch of other land
and it's like it's pretty good and my
mouth moves and you hear Spanish or you
hear Japanese or the two that I've seen
so far
so right now Sebastian was asking about
a job and that he would work for very
cheap right now it's crazy because it's
automation it would be a computer
program that would be doing that so
there's not currently any jobs available
but if there are we always announce it
on the show and listed on the website
all right thanks
okay Sebastian thank you appreciate the
phone call